president biden yucking it up with jimmy
kimmel on liberal late night the whole
thing was practically a therapy session
for the president who finds his poll
numbers hitting new lows the latest
brutal poll has his rating dropping to
33 percent quinnipiac
americans hoping to hear some sensible
solutions on the most urgent issues
hitting their pocketbook like inflation
getting this mostly rambling answer from
the commander-in-chief listen
inflation is the is the is the bane of
our existence
inflation is mostly in food and in
gasoline but here's the deal
you know my dad you say every every
family is a little bit of breathing room
if you take and look at all the costs
that a family has on a monthly basis it
also includes health care prescription
drugs child care all those things what
i'm proposing we get and i think we can
get it done i'm proposing that we in
fact reduce the cost of those things
all right greg he can't get it done they
already tried to get it they don't want
to do it okay
he's without question the worst
president in my lifetime and that is the
proof because we've talked about this
his solution for inflation is explaining
what inflation is here's the thing about
inflation
food prices go up
and what we're going to try to do and i
think this is going to work is maybe the
price get the prices you can get the
prices to go down unless it's gas
because we don't want you to use gas the
worst part about this whole thing is
that his presidency is ripe for mockery
and ridicule and even gentle humor if
you like him i mean just hunter biden
alone just in the recent stuff i mean
you could go on forever but kimmel has
abdicated his role of a comedian he's
now just a political hack and which i'm
grateful for because then i get to turf
to myself i'm not a comedian but i just
filled the gap that's why i'm beating
him every night because
he sat there with that guy and basically
he spoon fed him like he was a dementia
patient at a rest home he is yeah
oh janine
oh i didn't mean that
i'm so sorry
don't worry they'll they'll call you a
white supremacist and an insurrectionist
no there was there was no jokes though
last night i mean i watched it it wasn't
that funny usually the president's come
on and you've seen presidents go on who
is it
trump's hair all presidents have done it
yeah this didn't happen tonight last
night what do you want me to talk about
humor why why because the guy is
humorless all right the whole idea of
inflation is the bane of his existence
you know what he's doing he's making
sure that green energy is the bane of
our existence right that is his whole
conclusion you know what he's focused on
right now he's focused on making green
the solar panels which kind of reminds
me of what happened during the obama
administration do you remember solyndra
a half a billion dollars where the place
was bankrupt and they were still giving
them money and then they said we're
going to put the taxpayers at the end of
the line and get all our friends who
bundled so we could get into office now
you got biden he's up from now on the
solyndra is not solyndra but on solar
panels again you know that's all they
were interested in is making money and
prematurely getting us involved in green
energy didn't bush go on letterman and
do a few top tens yes is this pretty
cool as well was it
well i mean he would do them once in a
while but i mean you would the thing is
about this is
biden hasn't done an interview in 118
days wow but it was recently found out
that he
did an off-the-record visit to the air
force one that presses in the back he
went to visit them to complain about his
coverage oh really yeah but they
won't talk to them um
the whole reason that you have the clip
of bane of
uh inflation being the bane of our
existence it's not because kimmel
brought it up he didn't even ask him
it's the number one issue in america and
biden had to bring it up himself it's
not a good idea
to have nothing on your
plan in order to get something across
the finish line one of the reasons you
go on a late night show is that that's
your final push that's that you put your
shoulder behind it and like now we're
going to get it across do you remember
when president obama went on between two
firms yes okay oh that was hilarious
that was right before they were on the
cusp of passing obamacare obamacare and
they needed just a little bit more you
don't do that as your like only
interview that's what zach galifianakis
said funniest line he said what's it
like to be the first and last black
president
geraldo you remember was it uh
bella on a cineo hall with the saxophone
that was a real viral moment do you
think anything is going to happen
uh you know there's no good way to talk
about inflation the president is
absolutely right about that and he has
to do more of these interviews because
he absolutely stinks in terms of the
press conference he just can't do it he
starts reading he loses his place he's
not very effective in that presentation
but when he's there personable he's like
the grandpa is a he's much more
agreeable and i think people listen uh
listen more uh but the thing is he's got
to get the message across the economy's
not that bad i mean i understand
inflation you see the gas prices go up
it's obvious but the employment is at
3.6
unemployment's historic low unemployment
we've got he's got to sell the good
stuff and make america feel good about
him
can't do that when you have record high
inflation and gas prices people can have
a job but they can't afford to drive to
it right geraldo well i i think that uh
all right the 3.6
unemployment is historically low and he
should get some credit for that you'll
see that triple a uh report that like
what is it 30 40 increase in people
running out of gas on the highways
yeah
he's bringing hitchhiking back yes
good for me
[Laughter]
coming up as a giant caravan moves
through mexico the white house has a
plan to send the crisis to a town near
you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now